TODAY.
HE IS HAD A GREAT RECORD ALL
SEASON
AND, PUCK.
THE DEFENSIVEIT OUT.BARKOV.
THE SAVE IS MADE. DEFENSIVELY I
AND, THE PANTHERS FIND
THEMSELVES BEHIND A GOLD THIS
AFTERNOON.
>> Randy: IT IS
BEHIND THE NET.
LOCKED AWAY AND TAKEN AWAY.
HE'S SEE A PRETTY A KEY POWER-
PLAY OPPORTUNITY.   JONATHAN
HUBERDEAU TO KEGO IN THE SECOND
REPAIRS BEING DONE AT THE BENCH
DUCLAIR HUSTLING AGAINST NURSE.
MARCHMENT ON THE SIDE.
NO DOUBT.GOOD HIT BY CARLSSON.
HE HAD IT STOLEN AWAY BY  LEFT
LEG MAKING THAT COLLISION.GOOD
THE PANTNT
HUBERDEAU, GLOVE BYFOR
HUBERDEAU.
IT ALLUDED HIS S
>> Steve: THE ONLY SCORING
CHANCES THEY'VE HAD ARE
>> Randy: THE PANTHERS WERE
SURPRISED THERE WOULD BE A
PENALTY CALLED IN THE E  TRIES
THE BLOCK BY
THE POWER-PLAY.
THEY ARE NOT THE SECOND-BEST TO
HAVE  DIFFICULTIES, JUST IN THE
LAST SEQUENCE, TRYING TO GET
THAT PUCK THROUGH
JUOLEVI FIRES.
AND,  HIS
FIRST NHL HAT TRICK.NOW, BURY A
GAME. OMES THROUGH.
WE WILL SAY IF THE POWER PLAYS
CAN CONTINUE WITH FIVE ON FIVE.
PANTHERS. HEADS TO CENTER.
HERE'S EKBLAD.
CROSS ICE,  REINHART  WINS IT.
DUCLAIR FIRES.
SAVED BY SET UP BEAUTIFULLY FRO